[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du statut de société ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire pour des maths débattre
discuter et réfléchir sur les grands
enjeux qui font l'actualité
ce soir nous échangerons avec nos
invités sur la digitalisation des
entreprises et notamment celle des
commerçants et artisans en cette période
de crise sanitaire et confinement un
enjeu de compétitivité et de
productivité avec la crise de lakovic 19
la digitalisation la numérisation des
tpe pme et oatei ont pris une autre
envergure notamment pour les commerces
jugés non essentiels par l'état de la
fermeture totale au click and collect
nous tous n'ont pas fait le même choix
ce soir quatre invités ont accepté notre
invitation tout d'abord en plateau
alexandra dublanche bonsoir vous êtes la
vice-présidente au développement
économique au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france et en vision pour des
questions ça n'était sanitaire josé
destans conseiller municipal de
marly-le-roi vous êtes délégué au
commerce
bonsoir sinon jean philippe dayraut
loger consultant formateur au numérique
à la fédération 6 nov bonsoir
bonjour et dominique du lait vous êtes
dirigeant de secret d'intérieur une
boutique de décoration
installé au quai sous voies bon sens
raveau bonsoir alors le 28 octobre
dernier manuel macron annoncé un
deuxième confinement avec la fermeture à
nouveau de commerce jugés non essentiels
par l'état dominique duguet j'aimerais
commencer avec vous puisque vous êtes
commerçante est concerné cette fois par
contre vous n'avez pas totalement baissé
le rideau
puisque vous avez fait le pas vers
internet lui tout à fait j'ai dû fermer
le bain quand tout le monde jeudi soir
et dès mardi nous avons lancé le click
and collect on n'a jamais un blog déjà
enfant en fonctionnement et nous avons
fait en quatre jours un site internet
nous avons déjà lancé le site donc le
mardi
avec 500 produits et nous avons fait
tout ça en en quatre jours josé destans
en tant qu'élu d'une collectivité que
vous êtes conseiller municipal à
marly-le-roi l'annoncé d'un 2ème
confinement ça a été vécue de quelle
manière
alors nous étions finalement bien
préparé je dirai pas ce que un petit peu
avant l'été
nous avions commencé à réfléchir à la
mise en place d'une plateforme numérique
et nos choix durant la période estivale
et s'est porté sur une plateforme qui
s'appelle ma vie mon shopping et nous
avons à ce jour 50 % des commerçants de
marly le roi qui auront adhéré à cette
plateforme
alors la digitalisation n'est pas
toujours facile pour des raisons de
compétences de connaissances techniques
mais aussi parfois de moyens
alexandra du blanche depuis la fin de
l'année 2018 depuis plus tôt début 2019
la région apporte un soutien financier
grâce au chèque numérique qu'est ce que
c'est ce chèque exactement on a essayé
de lancer ce mouvement depuis un moment
et bien sûr il ya une accélération avec
le premier confinement c'est une aide
pour les commerces comme celui de madame
qui vient de s'exprimer pour les aider à
créer un site internet donc c'est un
chèque de 1500 euros créé un site
internet faire de la publicité digitale
on l'a beaucoup élargi pendant le
premier confinement par exemple en
incluant les frais de livraison pour les
restaurateurs en finançant aussi de la
formation au numérique et on l'a fait
aussi évoluer pour un chèque pour les
communes donc par exemple marly la ville
de marly le roi vient de bénéficier
aujourd'hui même d'une subvention de la
région qui vient d'être votée ça peut
aller jusqu'à dix mille euros pour
financer des plateformes locales pour du
click and collect ou de l'achat
ligne quand on choisit vous avez choisi
le montant le plus élevé qu est ce qui a
fait que ces 1500 euros et 10000 euros
alors mes 500 euros c'est pour nous
c'était une aide incitative pour
vraiment encourager les commerçants à
aller dans cette voie et ensuite pour
les communes on s'est rendu compte que
ces plateformes coûte entre 20 et 40
mille euros selon les services que l'on
prend donc les 10000 euros permettent de
financer entre un quart et la moitié du
coût de la plate forme donc ça nous a
paru assez juste
josé destans justement madame du blanc
je viens de le dire marly le roi s'était
portée candidate et a obtenu ce chèque
pourquoi vous avez fait cette demande
c'était un soutien financier dont vous
aviez besoin du nord est ce que c'est
pour une commune
c'est un investissement glem
relativement important on parle de dix
mille euros c'est quand même
significatif donc l'ile-de-france en
prennent 50 60 %
c'est extrêmement beau c'est une aide
très concrètes sur les finances locales
jean-philippe derlot quels sont les axes
les obstacles ou les difficultés s'il y
en a qu'on peut rencontrer quand on est
une tpe une pme ou qu'on est un artisan
beaucoup d'entreprises malheureusement
réagissent avec le numérique
un petit peu comme le consommateur avec
l'assurance c'est quand ils ont
l'accident qui se posent la question de
souscrire un contrat d'assurance est en
fait le numérique comme vient de le
souligner monsieur josé destans c'est
une question de 2,2 d'anticipation et
cette capacité qu'il faut avoir à avoir
un peu de visibilité pour que se
préparer est importante
aujourd'hui les commerçants qui n'ont
pas pris le temps de bien s'équiper sont
un peu démunis et la difficulté c'est
que les moyens financiers les
subventions par par la région ou par
l'état puisque cédric rouge vient aussi
d'annoncer des z sont les très bienvenus
mais la difficulté c'est que les
entreprises tpe artisans ne sont ne se
sont pas fait une culture numérique a
minima en s'informant suivant des
formations ligne 7 8 et a énormément
et bien malheureusement il de ils les
ont du mal à d
c'est principalement la vie justement
acquiescé c'est légende à vous présenter
un projet avant de vous dire renier le
chèque numérique pour vous assurer que
ils ont aussi les moyens de le faire
alors non parce qu'il faut que ça soit
très simple il faut pas qu'il ya un
obstacle déjà on a vraiment du mal à ce
que on a eu du mal à ce que ce mouvement
s'enclenche donc effectivement comme
vient de le dire monsieur il a fallu une
crise pour que vraiment les beaucoup de
commerçants prennent conscience de la
nécessité du numérique
après ce qui est très important
effectivement c'est la formation déjà
nous quand on a lancé ce dispositif
on n'a pas voulu on essaye d'éviter les
doublons pour une termes d'efficacité
donc on a vu que la cci la chambre de
métiers notamment faisait de la
formation et donc on est on est arrivés
en complément est donc maintenant même
des formations à monsieur ça peut
rentrer dans le financement du chèque
numérique de la formation numérique pour
avoir une culture plus long terme
dominique duguet vous êtes lancé comment
il ya eu beau salariés qui vous ont aidé
vos proches mais vous aviez des
connaissances alors moi j'ai pas
vraiment le connaissant le bon j'ai la
chance d'avoir un mari qui est
informaticien mais qui n'est pas du tout
dans le domaine du web
mais bon c'est un peu plus facile et
comme je vous le disais j'avais déjà un
blog dont en partant du blog
on a créé ce pronostic internet et on
travaille avec un outil très simple
témoin
wordpress qui est un outil totalement
gratuit et très accessible très facile à
manipuler
j'en suis libre desranleau aujourd'hui
aussi il ya énormément de réseaux
sociaux beaucoup de commerces comme
unique de cette manière est ce que le
site internet est toujours un outil
rechercher où finalement il faut
aujourd'hui encore s'adapter
oui c'est à nous qui est indispensable
mais complémentaires aux réseaux sociaux
pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que la majorité des consommateurs quand
ils cherchent un produit le premier
réflexe qu'ils ont c'est d'aller sur
leur moteur de recherche préféré google
qui détient 95% de parts de marché et le
fait d'avoir un blog comme je le
soulignais à mme duguay est un très bon
moyen pour pouvoir avoir une bonne
visibilité et faire que quand vous allez
taper les mots clés ou quand un
consommateur à taper les mots clés qui
recherchent un produit qu'elle est peu
commun c est bien
le consommateur en question va
nécessairement tomber ou 13 avait
beaucoup de chance tombé sur la page du
site internet de cette entreprise si
elle a pris le temps et c'est là
prennent soin de se développer et de se
donner de la lisibilité avec un blog le
premier conseil que vous donnez à une
entreprise un artisan qui vient vous
voir sur cette question là j'ai envie
d'être vus j'ai envie de passer au
numérique les réseaux sociaux sont
complémentaires aux blogs ou sites
internet et vont permettre d' amplifier
le signal en fait mais le premier
critère technique c'est d'avoir un site
ou un blog dans un cas comme nadal
duguay mais il ne faut pas oublier donc
une un point très important qui la
satisfaction client c'est parce que vous
avez des clientes ils sont satisfaits
que derrière tout ce que vous allez
faire via le numérique va pouvoir être
amplifiées et explosé en termes de
visibilité de chiffre d'affaires
dominique duguet je vous voyais vous d'y
intervenir lui tout à fait parce que les
réseaux sociaux sont vraiment liés avec
le site j'ai fait également une boutique
peu sur facebook et du coup qui est lié
directement au site
on découvre le produit sûr que vous
venez au quai et on va sur le coup pour
l'acheter donc ça c'est vraiment très
important et réseaux sociaux sont
essentiels mais le site également leur
permettre aux professionnels de
continuer à faire vivre leur commerce
après la mise en place d'un groupe sur
un réseau social saint quentin en
yvelines poursuit son accompagnement
l'agglomération va bientôt proposer un
nouvel un nouvel outil l'application
shop in sky c'est un marché virtuel
réunissant les commerçants des douze
communes du territoire
les explications de didier fischer vice
président en charge du commerce
l'entretien est réalisé par nicolas
landry
[Musique]
c'est une application importante
évidemment puisque elle permet pour les
clients d'avoir dans leur poche
l'ensemble des dirait des commerces de
saint quentin et pour les commerces et
d'être en contact effectivement d'être
une boutique en ligne en quelque sorte d
être en contact avec leurs oeufs avec
leurs clients c'était une idée qui qui
existait depuis quelques mois mais dans
le contexte actuel vous pouvez
comprendre qu'on a accéléré le processus
parce que c'est une aide indispensable à
l'heure actuelle aux clients parlent
beaucoup à l'heure actuelle du cri comme
en collecte bien et cesser cela d'une
certaine façon c'est cela il sait mettre
à disposition des commerçants une
application qui est une application
gratuite pour eux et qui va permettre en
principe de les aider dans la période
actuelle
le 20 novembre l'application sera en
ligne
il suffira pour eux de charger cette
application est ensuite ils n'ont plus
qu'à naviguer sur cette application
choisir les commerces dans lesquels ils
souhaitent d'une manière se rendent
donne déjà dans un premier temps d'une
manière virtuelle et ensuite d'une
manière plus concrète en allant retirer
les produits qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
acheté alors cette question de la
digitalisation des entreprises du
soutien aux commerçants dans leur
transition numérique c'est le thème du
sky échos du 13 novembre dernier le
magazine préparée et présentée par
nicolas landry est à voir et à revoir
sur notre site internet
alors on retrouve nos invités pour
parler de cette digitalisation des
entreprises josé destans saint quentin
en yvelines a fait le choix d'une
application mobile à marly-le-roi vous
êtes dirigés vers une plateforme
internet ma ville mon shopping ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure pourquoi ce
choix
alors ce choix s'il voulait il semble y
remplir et bien checker un certain
nombre de fonctionnalités qui nous
paraissaient importantes
on pense qu'il ya des changements très
significative dans les habitudes de
consommation lié à cette crise sanitaire
mais il ya également une tendance de
fond donc on voulait un outil qui nous
accompagnent et bien dans le moyen et le
long terme
cette plateforme répondez à nos besoins
parce que en fait elle permettait
d'avoir une utilisation à la carte et
steria qu'en fait on pouvait l'utiliser
en conversant pour l'utiliser pour un
simple référencement il pouvait
l'utiliser pour faire du clic and
collect c'est à dire en fait de l'achat
en ligne avec retrait en magasin ils
pouvaient également faire la réservation
en ligne avec paiement eux en boutique
et puis y avait la fonctionnalité
livraison par prono cost puisque ma
ville mon shopping est une filiale
donc c'est pour toutes ces raisons s'ils
voulaient marie leroy nous avons proposé
à nos commerçants
cette plateforme au 16 novembre 50
commerces installés communes ont rejoint
cette plateforme il a été dur de l'est
de les amener avec vous au contraire
c'était presque qui vous pousse est faux
il faut de toute façon effectivement un
certain nombre de ressources sur le
terrain pour aller voir les commerçants
arabes et pour leur présenter leurs
plateformes
mais au-delà de ça il faut un plan de
communication solide on a commencé je
voulais par une campagne qui taurian
dans le journal la chronique le journal
interne à marly nous avons fait
également de l'affichage dans les abris
bus étant le des panneaux d'affichage au
co nous allons nous avons une campagne
numérique a parlé tout à l'heure il est
important d'avoir une campagne numérique
et digitales sur facebook sur instagram
sur le site de la ville de marly le roi
et nous avons également fait du tractage
dans les boîtes à lettres
cette phase de ce plan de communication
il est quasiment aussi important que
tout le reste
parce qu'il faut faire connaître cette
plateforme omar ly choix jean-philippe
des avants l'eau est ce qu'aujourd'hui
on peut dire que c'est vital de faire sa
transition numérique on ne peut plus
attendre
c'est c'est indispensable alors venir ce
retour on le dit on ne tourne a de cesse
de répéter le bon côté du convient de 19
de la pandémie
d'une certaine façon je vais pas dire
que c'est un chose qui est la bienvenue
dans tous les cas ça a fait réagir
beaucoup d'entreprises qui se sont qui a
accéléré le processus pour s'approprier
numérique
il y en a encore qui sont à la traîne et
il faut que toutes ces entreprises
prennent le temps d'aller se documenter
s'informer via internet encore une fois
il ya des formations en ligne à des
tutoriels sur youtube il ya des mots des
massive online le plan consiste gratuit
par les différentes écoles les grands
établissements français
on a toute la matière qu'il faut pour
pouvoir apprendre il faut simplement
prendre le temps se donner l'énergie dit
elle et je pense que c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'a fait visiblement manning et même
si elle
chance effectivement d'être accompagné
d'un mari informaticien alexandra
dublanchet ce que vous voyez plus de
demandes pour ce chèque puisqu'il est
assez jeune mais j'imagine qu'avec la
crise les gens se sont rendu compte
qu'ils avaient vraiment besoin
effectivement ça a pris beaucoup
d'ampleur depuis le mois de mars on a à
peu près 10 fois plus de demandes
qu'auparavant donc il faut vraiment
amplifié on est beaucoup de partenaires
à travailler ensemble là dessus donc
nous on est sur le financement il ya
d'autres acteurs qui sont sur la
formation en amont sur aussi
l'identification du meilleur dispositif
certains voudront effectivement faire un
site internet d'autres auront besoin
juste d'être mieux localiser sur voilà
des plateforme de géolocalisation et
donc il faut voilà est trop sûrs d'eux
sur mesure et puis faire évoluer parfois
des dispositifs pour qu'ils s'adaptent à
tout un tas de situations
dominique duguet on a vu il ya donc
cette application mobile qui va arriver
pour saint quentin en yvelines vous êtes
sur le territoire de l'agglomération
vous avez votre propre site internet
est ce que vous allez aussi vous lancer
sur cette application vous allez
retrouver en intérêt aussi
oui je pense que moi je vais y trouver
un intérêt surtout au niveau de la
communication pour me faire connaître
dans les autres villes rues aux
alentours
en revanche la difficulté avec la
gestion du stock parce que je vais avoir
mon propre site internet
si je suis aussi sur cette plateforme il
y aura les ventes en magasin en fait en
petit magasin on n'a pas beaucoup de
stock
on a trois quatre produits phares 3,4
produit par préférence en fait et ça ça
va être par contre un problème à gérer
mais pour se faire connaître je trouve
que cette plate forme et est super
intéressante et commerçants qui ont pas
de luffy d'autant plus alors on sait que
la future échéance qui arrive c'est noël
c'est l'une des périodes les plus
prolifiques pour les commerces et
notamment cette occasion avec sandra
dublanche la région elle aussi un lance
sa plateforme est ce qu'on peut on dire
un petit mot
cette affaire nous on est très inquiets
par la fermeture de ces commerces soit
disant un homme essentiel je trouve le
mot d'ailleurs très très mal choisi
donc avec valérie pécresse c'est vrai
qu'on on est à l'écouté des demandes des
commerçants et nous on demande
évidemment de les aider par rapport à
noël on est complètement incertain sur
la date de réouverture nous on demande
avec la présidente d'une réouverture le
27 nov
c'est le jour du black friday que ça
serait catastrophique pour nos petits
commerçants et on lance une opération
sur noël sur une plate forme mais
commerce pour elle de france.fr le but
c'est pas de multiplier les plateformes
mais c'est vraiment d'inciter les
franciliens à acheter en local et au
plus près de chez eux et dont tout tous
les commerces et une en partenariat avec
les sauts locale donc c'est la poste
également tous les commerces sont
référencés et donc c'est encore plus
pour un autre moyen d'attirer
l'attention sur nos petits commerçants
josé testant justement ça peut être de
noël vous allez renforcer lé plus auprès
des commerçants leur disant il ya cette
plateforme qui existe de fait de travers
du plan de communication dont je vous ai
parlé nous nous axons tous nos efforts
sur effectivement la prise en main d'une
part des coûts de la plateforme par les
commerçants et d'autres pas
l'information auprès des marins du choix
afin de faire connaître cette norme
c'est extrême rigueur notre critique
jean phi desranleau on a principalement
parlé des commerces durant cette
émission parce que c'est ce peut-être
les plus touchées actuellement mais la
digitalisation des entreprises concerne
toutes les entreprises il faut pas se
laisser dépasser par une autre qui fait
la même activité
alors c'est sûr que le principe de la
visibilité sur internet ce sont surtout
les entreprises qui vont être proactif
sur internet qui vont être visible est
un des moyens extrêmement simple dont
encore beaucoup d'entreprises n'ont pas
conscience c'est tout simplement avec
les smartphones et de la qualité des
smartphones que l'on a aujourd'hui quel
que soit le modèle que l'on utilise on
peut très faire très facilement faire
des petites vidéos qui vont permettre de
parler de ses services de sont produites
ces réalisations que l'on soit
commerçant que l'on soit disant et là
encore il ya vraiment beaucoup de
développement à faire pour que les 50 g
de développement bout il faut vraiment
former informer et je m'y emploie la
fédération si nous sommes informés des
artisans et des commerçants pour qu'ils
s'approprient le mieux possible ce type
d'outil qui aujourd'hui sont gratuits
les ont tous dans la poche mais ils
n'ont pas encore le réflexe de les
utiliser et de bien de bien les
exploiter pour se donner de la
visibilité
qu'est ce qui me fait qu'il n'ya pas ses
réflexes une inquiétude parfois
peut-être lié à des générations aussi le
fait que les réseaux se développe très
vite aussi un moment principalement un
manque de curiosité un manque
d'initiative
on est dans une société en france on a
toujours peur de d'être jugés d'être
critique est sûre quand on se rend
visible mais il faut se jeter à l'eau et
puis c'est comme ça qu'on apprend à se
servir du numérique un les enfants quand
ils apprennent à marcher les premiers
pas il tombe ils sont mal au genou
et puis progressivement il avance et
puis un moment ils vont devenir
équilibristes et ils vont courir avec
leurs copains et bien au niveau du
numérique c'est vraiment l'identique il
faut que les artisans se lance sujette à
l'eau apprennent à se servir de ces
outils partagent avec leurs pairs ça
c'est un très bon moyen ou scinder au
sein des syndicats professionnels ou
simples des chambres de métiers les
chambres de commerce de pouvoir partager
ses expériences passées pme le fait
énormément
il faut pas se priver de d'échangés
entre pairs faut stimuler faut que les
gens soient curieux
dominique duguet notamment m'ont parlé
avec les téléphones on peut tout faire
maintenant que ce film et vous êtes me
lancer dans du visio shopping vous avez
des prochaines idées à proposer à vos
clients
pas pour l'instant pas fait déjà hyper
correctement ce que j'ai lancé donc
effectivement jeter le visio shopping
c'est à dire que je suis dans le magasin
les clients sont chez eux et je leur
présente les produits qu'ils souhaitent
acheter quand ils ont des questions pour
avoir des conseils et ou pas je les
conseille en me promenant dans le
magasin et on leur montre les produits
un par un voilà ça fonctionne bien mais
ça demande effectivement beaucoup
beaucoup d'investissements tout ça mais
ça vaut tout je suis contente du
résultat en tout cas le click and
collect elle vidyo shopping auction
qu'un josé descend aussi vous
réfléchissez à d'autres solutions
peut-être numériques pour accompagner
vos commerçants ou même la ville de
toute façon tous toutes les solutions
sont bonnes
on a fait le choix d'une plateforme on
est vraiment concentré sur cette
plateforme
on développe d'importants moyens pour
que ça fonctionne on insiste beaucoup
les commerçants sublet pour se mettre en
ligne et se dire que il faut aller les
voir il faut leur dire de mettre 20 25
30 photos voire une centaine de photos
faut vraiment les assister les soutenir
afin que l'opération globalement
fonctionne c'est très important dans
cette dans cette période mais aussi
s'est révélé logique en fait on leur
montre comment faire
et puis prennent un peu plus d'autonomie
déresponsabilisation au rock
le cheikh eux mêmes on va finir avec une
minute après chacun je voudrais
commencer avec vous jean philippe
dayraut l'eau pour motiver ou conseiller
les derniers réticents qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire quel est le truc le plus
facile est de dire sa propre temps mais
ça donne du résultat je pense que le
plus simple c'est tout simplement
d'aller voir ses confrères qui utilisent
le numérique et puis de leur demander de
nous aider de nous expliquer de se faire
expliquer de se faire aimer de se faire
accompagner pour pouvoir justement
s'approprier le numérique
parce qu'en fait s'ils s'adressent à
leurs pairs ils comprendront beaucoup
plus et beaucoup plus facilement parce
qu'il parle du même métier
ils sont plus associés partenaires que
concurrents et ils vont jouer la carte
de la complémentarité et c'est
collectivement qu'ils vont avancer
ensemble
dominique duguet
vous disiez vos clients sont satisfaits
est-ce qu'il y en a que vous n'avez pas
réussi à retrouver encore et que grâce à
tous ces moyens numériques vous espérez
les faire revenir avec vous excusez moi
j'étais un petit peu vu l'empreinte de
connexion pourriez vous répéter votre
question savoir si vous avez des clients
que vous n'avez pas encore revue parce
qu'ils n'ont pas encore compris
connaissance que vous nous aviez tout
ses moyens numériques
oui bien oui bien sûr mes jambes je fais
encore une autre action c'est à dire que
j'ai eu un très bon fichier clients les
gens vous j'ai envoyé plus de 2000 e
mail en leur annonçant le 6 donc
effectivement je suis quand même créé ni
même si tous ne sont pas revenus qui
vont venir
oui enfin qu'à une énorme solidarité des
clients
beaucoup sont venus pour me m'apporter
leur soutien en achetant des petites
choses ou des gros ou des choses
important mais vraiment garrel soutien
des clients et ils tiennent vraiment à
leur commerce de proximité ça jeu j'en
suis j'en suis persuadé et ça va en
progressant depuis le premier
confinement les clientes ont de plus en
plus de fidèles je trouve et josette et
ce temps vous sur marley le roi est ce
que vous voyez que cette plateforme les
gens y vont et en fait ce que ça
fonctionne de passer au numérique en
avantage il est une plateforme comme
celle que nous allons en tenue de ski
effectivement on reçoit certain nombre
d'indicateurs très facile ici et semaine
et on voit la progression qu'on voit le
nombre de vues entre le nombre de
boutiques en ligne le nombre de produits
donc on a des critères gérer très très
factuelle si aussi pour ça qu'on a
choisi chevauchent type de plateforme et
alexandre un doublon je vais terminer
avec vous est ce que le but notamment et
que ce chèque numérique c'est qu'un jour
toutes les tpe pme entreprises
d'ile-de-france soit trop vague sur
internet et opter on pense que c'est
c'est indispensable au delà de la crise
que nous traversons moi ce que je
voudrais dire ce soir c'est quand je
vois le dynamisme de ces commerçants je
le voyais sartrouville moi où je suis
élue au commerce c'est c'est vraiment
impressionnant
c'est admirable et et nous par exemple
on met beaucoup l'accent justement sur
la formation de nos commerçants à
sartrouville et donc voila moi je leur
souhaite surtout beaucoup de courage
et là avec des aides qui ne règle pas
tous les problèmes j'en ai bien
conscience mais en tout cas on est
vraiment à leurs côtés et on espère que
noël se passera bien et qui aura un
rattrapage important de chiffre
d'affaires merci on va se quitter sur
ces mots c'est la fin de ce sept huit
sociétés merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce 7,8 société est à revoir sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle émission
[Musique]